welcome back to the next big game
titanfall earlier this week we talked to
the folks at respawn about their
four-year journey building the game but
today we're going to focus in on the two
players in this delicately balanced game
of death this is pilots vs titans if
there is a single defining element that
makes titanfall feel like a new breed of
first-person shooter it's the varying
levels of combat that take place between
pilots and titans and if there was a
single concern gamers hard about
titanfall it's how do you ensure battles
between soldiers and super powered robot
suits are fair and balanced the
relationship between pilots and titans
is at the core of typing for it defines
how you approach combat it dictates the
tactical decisions you make and it's at
the root of Y titanfall is such an
interesting game from talking to the
team behind titanfall it's clear this
has been a delicate balancing act right
from the very start how do you make
controlling a typing feel powerful
without hindering the pilot side of
gameplay to get to the root of this we
asked titanfall game director Steve
Fukuda what it's like stepping into the
shoes of either first up pilots well
what the great thing about being a pilot
is that you can run off the walls double
jump your maneuverability is very high
so when you're in like a built-up area
where there's lots of buildings lots of
interiors you generally have a bit of an
edge over the Titan to want to be
creative and imaginative looking at the
environments I hate can I go that way
that way or think about your exit
strategy at every moment say okay if
something happens here for Titan comes
around that corner where am I actually
going to go if I gonna go book it for
that wall and then kick off that wall go
through that window how am I gonna do
this so what kind of weapons do I have
that's another area of the key factor in
is what are my anti Titan weapons i have
for example the archer heavy rocket
that's something i'm going to want to
lock on from a distance and i'm going to
want to use it against a an advanced
player they're gonna notice that you're
walking out of them so you got to be
careful that you're not the only thing
they're worrying about if they're busy
fighting is another Titan or their
fixated on target fixated on something
this is a good opportunity to use that
weapon if there's considerable amounts
of damage or finish a guy off if you're
using the Sidewinder you have to lead
the target considerably and it helps a
lot to get in close and aim for those
critical points on the Titans when you
drop its shields
so what you've got terms of abilities as
well you have stim do you have cloak as
a pilot you have to use cloaking in
order to make yourself more or less
invisible to the Titans so you can
actually be sitting there you have that
Jurassic Park moment with a t-rex is
there and they don't see you there using
cloaking is really important in there
but you might you can't have that and
stem at the same time stem allows you to
move very quickly through the level for
short periods of time how you play what
your style is what you feel your
strengths are as a player as a pilot on
the ground the factor into their above
all else don't get into a pissing match
of the Titan in the open ground this is
like that's why cloaks help on the open
ground it's your one saving grace if you
don't have clothes uses stem need to
rethink your strategy later the team at
respawn seemed to have put a lot of
effort into ensuring Titans feel
powerful but vulnerable enough that the
right weapon and some sort of lateral
thinking can result in a
david-versus-goliath style kill a
delicate balancing act indeed and not
one that came about easily yeah the
hardest thing about balancing the Titans
in the pilots in titanfall was making it
fair for both sides at one point the
Titans had regenerating health so they
were able to fully regenerate their
health and it sucked as a pilot because
you hit them with something and you're
risking your life and even though you
might hit them they're just going to
regenerate that health infuriating so we
ended up having to make pilot weapons
that would work capable of killing a
Titan very quickly which then made it
frustrating to be a Titan and then
Titans were getting killed by pilots
like that but they'd fight other Titans
forever that didn't make sense so then
we ended up with this other health
system that would kind of take their
health down permanently but then you
found that when you're at ten percent as
a Titan your time was basically useless
so you wouldn't want to engage another
tie and you didn't feel comfortable you
didn't feel safe walking around you'd
end up just abandoning it so we ended up
with the system that we have now which
is the Titans shield will always
regenerate but they are always taking a
little bit of permanent damage
when they're hit and so even as a pilot
if you're not able to finish off the
Titan you know that you didn't just
damage it's showed you did damage it a
little bit permanently and if you're
really good as a pilot or you use the
right scale or you attack the right way
or you catch an unassuming Titan you can
finish it off well we had this whole
notion of at first because Titans were
the relatively unknown design space or
unexplored design space for us anyway
you know robots and games there they
call max yet you've got a something of a
bad reputation they're known as being
slow and unwieldy and there they can
also be complicated and very simulator
oriented so we want to do is sort of
make sure that as a pilot your
experience as a pod and your familiarity
with those kinds of controls with
translate voice transitionary smoothly
into the experience of a tightness of
the titans tend to be fairly mobile very
smooth and someone agile depending on
which of the Titan chassis you're using
it was kind of fortuitous that we
finally arrived at this very martial
arts meets jet fighter pilot kind of
dynamic as far as Titans Titans go but
the battlefields of titanfall aren't
just about pilots and Titans there's a
third player in the combat who I it's
just as much to the power struggle the
AI combatants not only did they
encourage new players to engage in
combat and act as a fun way to take time
off your titanfall counter but their
vulnerability contrasts the strength of
the human players titanfall isn't a game
about one shot kills battles are valets
of gunfire and dodging echoing past
Titans of online shooting like unreal
tournament and quake instead of being a
disposable soldier you feel like you're
an important player in a larger battle
and the AI creep certainly plays its
part the AI in titanfall are there for a
multitude of reasons they were never
ever in there to replace players that
was something that we never considered
it literally yeah these guys are awesome
look at the things they can do they they
make new players feel good about
themselves they make great players feel
like badasses like still to this day one
of my favorite things to do is just a
wall run with a smart festival bounce
off walls while locking on the bunch of
grunts below just picking them off while
I'm working my
way to wherever I'm trying to go
multiplayer can be a zero-sum game where
someone's getting a lot of kills that
mean someone's dying a lot so you know
we have the grunts and the spectres in
AI that are relatively easy to kills for
new players is something to get instant
gratification get a sense of progress
and without getting beaten down with the
for advanced players they turn out to be
more like target practice but they add
also the vibrance of the lower the sense
of activity and the cinematic nature now
as Titans so start coming back from
survivability that's what Titans provide
to a large extent for new players it was
important actually to have make sure
that there were fights you know Bert so
often shooters I think they moved into
this direction which once upon time was
very fresh you know back and remember
the original rainbow six it was like
bang you're dead banging it it took out
a justement period actually to get used
to that having come off to say quake
back with it but with this game we
wanted to make sure we had fights like
actual I shoot at you you should at me
we don't just whoever sees the other guy
first isn't going to necessarily just
end it it's like it's gonna be a bit of
play there oh now the fights on fights
on in titanfall respawn have attempted
to create a game in which you always
have your part to play in the battle and
if they've pulled it off then no matter
if you're piloting a powerful mechanical
suit or running along the side of a
building and collecting headshots you'll
always have a story to tell you know
what other games you have a situation
where you're on top of a Titan some of
that guy's realizes you're there so he
decides to eject eject but that since
both of you flying into the air you're
in the air shooting at each other air
controlling meanwhile people are
shooting up at you from below and then
you get close enough he makes a mistake
so you kick him in midair he goes flying
to his dropping you land on the ground
his corpse hits the ground you then jump
out other tightening keep on rolling and
riding that wave and you have this you
have you'll have so many stories to tell
of your own in this game and it's all
it's always visceral always cinemax
always a story to tell as a player and
it's a very unique experience that way
that was a breakdown of the relationship
between pilots and Titans in titanfall
later this week on the next big game we
break apart the anatomy of a titan forum
app and talk to respawn co-founder vince
zampella about life after call of duty
make sure to catch all that or more all
this week over on gamespot com
you